hello
my name is david bizzaro and i'm a
professor in the department of molecular
genetics at the ohio state university
and it's a pleasure for me to talk with
you today
um
i've spent most of my career in
working on the dna containing gemini
viruses and in fact we still are very
active in that area
but today's talk is about viroids
and
before i begin
i would like to acknowledge two
individuals first my late colleague
dr biao ding
who was an outstanding
scholar
and
investigator
and who is responsible for me getting
interested in viroids in the first place
and i'd also like to acknowledge dr john
wu
a graduate student and post-doc in the
lab who single-handedly is responsible
for all the data i'm going to show you
today and much more besides
so
the title of my talk is really quite
specific it's about bias paul ii
fidelity
uh
in
contributing to conservation in the
potato spindle tuber viroid genome
but before i go into that i'm going to
give you some background about viroids
some of you may not be familiar with
them
so
viroites
are the smallest known plant pathogens
they are circular single-stranded rnas
ranging in size from about 250 to 400
nucleotides
they encode no proteins
and they're basically unencapsidated
infectious rnas and these were
discovered in 1971 by ted diener who's
shown here up on the left
now
viroids are placed in two families
depending on their structure and
functional characteristics
avocado sun blotch viroid is the type
member of the absent viroidae
these are mostly branched structures
and they replicate in the chloroplast
of infected infected plant cells
and
they have intrinsic ribozyme activity
embedded within the rna
this talk is going to be concerned with
the pos b viridae specifically the type
member potato spindle tumor vibroid
these are mostly rod shaped and they
replicate in the nucleus
and do not have ribozyme
activity now
viroites have to do a lot of things
as viruses do and they accomplish all
this
simply using rna sequence and rna
structure
a really remarkable thing
they have a lot in common
once they get into the cell they need to
find the appropriate organelle in the
case of some the chloroplast in the case
of pstbd
the nucleus they replicate within the
organelle
they are then exported from that
organelle
and go to adjacent cells
so they must traffic cell to cell
and eventually make their way into the
vascular tissue specifically usually the
phloem
where they can spread long distance
relatively rapidly and exit the form
to invade new cells and while doing all
this they need to evade host defenses so
there's really a lot to do
for small rna
now
a little more about pstbd its genome is
shown here
it's a circular non-coding rna as i
mentioned before of
359 nucleotides
and again all functions required for
infection
are mediated by the rna sequence and
structure itself
now the genome folds into a rod shaped
structures is very highly structured
that contains 17
gu base pairs these are
wobble bases mostly and these are
indicated by the red ticks at the bottom
here
and 27 loops and bulges which are
numbered across the top here
now these appear to be non-paired in
this in this diagram but in fact they're
that's not the case these all have 3d
structure due to non-watson crick base
pairing
base stacking and other sorts of
interactions
for example a model of the loop 27
structure is shown here
below
now we've been greatly aided in our
research by
two individuals i want to acknowledge
uh neoquest leontis and craig zerbel
both at bowling green state university
unfortunately
dr leontes passed away
very recently
but without the input of these
outstanding structural biologists
much of what we've done so far would not
be possible
a focus in the lab is to determine
the roles of the 3d struct
3d structured loops and gu pairs
in
pstvd trafficking and replication
so let's talk about that for a minute
so
like plant viruses
viroids move cell to cell through
structures called plasmodesmata
which are cytoplasmic connections
between cells that actually bridge the
cellulose cell wall
and ultimately of course they get into
the vascular system as i mentioned
earlier
now as infectious non-coding rnas virus
are really excellent models to study rna
transport
implants and what we've learned so far
in many years of investigation in dr
ding's laboratory and now mine
is essentially that all gu pairs have
important roles in psdbd trafficking and
replication sometimes both
rna loops also are critical for rna
trafficking and or replication
and
surprisingly different gu pairs and 3d
loops mediate
pstvd transport between different cell
types
and very often in a directional manner
so that suggests that all plasmodesmata
are not the same that is there are
different requirements for rna to move
between different cell types
so just to amplify that point
this is a diagram across of a
cross-section of a leaf in this case
it's an inoculated leaf we typically
inoculate
on the epidermis which is the upper
grayish uh cell layer there that you see
and the viroid needs to move out of that
layer down into
mesophyll cells below
of course it can move laterally within
layers as well and and then it gets into
the phloem
shown by the red arrow
and
for long distance transport now up into
the right you'll see a systemic leaf and
you'll see the viroid exiting
the rna exiting
the phloem and then
subsequently invading that leaf as well
excuse me
now
as an example of directional path uh
transport
the psdvd loop 27 which in the psdvd
genome shown at the top is the terminal
loop
there on the right
we found that that particular loop
an intact loop 27 is required
for the for the pstvd rna to exit the
epidermis in the inoculated leaf and
invade cells below
surprisingly
if we put the virate on the other side
of the barrier
that is the mutant virus on the other
side of the barrier for example by
inoculating it into the phloem we find
that it's perfectly capable of moving
between all other cell types and even
invading the epidermis in systemically
infected leads so
it's essentially a one-way ticket
required for epidermal exit but not
entry
fascinating so
there's a diagram here of a very crude
one of plasmodesma
of a plasmodesmata if you will
and we know very little about how these
things function
uh in fact there are proteins there that
regulate the gating
and and presumably these are different
between different cell types but we
really know very little about about how
this occurs and and really the next
frontier will be to figure out what host
factors recognize the elements that are
required for this rna transport
okay now back to pstvd replication
pstvd replicates the nucleus where it
hijacks host dna dependent rna
polymerase ii this is the enzyme that
transcribes dna into mrnas
it transcribes pstbd rna using a rolling
circle mechanism as we'll we'll see in a
minute
uh we don't know much about how it
manages to use a non-native template rna
in this case
but we do know that a plant-specific
variant of transcription factor 3a
enhances poly2 transcription of pstbd
now 3a tf3a is actually a a factor that
typically works with rna polymerase 3.
so there's a lot we don't know about
this process either
the only other thing that i can tell you
for certain is that some of the
structured loops and gu pairs are
critical for pstbd replication
the only other example i'm aware of of
paul ii transcribing an rna
is hepatitis delta virus
excuse me here
okay
now
i want to bring your attention to a
couple of things first on the far left
um
the pstvd transcription domain
this is a region
where paul two binds and tf-3a
c7
the the
transcription factor bind within that
domain
so it's a region that's critical for
replication another region is in the
center the central region
where you see right around between loops
for
loops 13 to 15
uh
this region is
also essential for replication as well
as for processing
uh the genomic rna as we'll see in a
minute
now um loopy is
a motif that was initially recognized in
ribosomal rna so this is a motif that's
found in a lot of different rnas and you
can see there's an annotation there of
the non-canonical base pairing within it
i'm not going to have time to go through
those non-canonical base pairs
but just be aware of that now something
i will come back to in this talk are the
terminal conserved region and the
central conserved region and i've
indicated those with red bars
uh on the genome sequence
uh we'll come back to these in a minute
these are obviously conserved
because of their critical roles in
replication and genome processing
now let's drill down on the rolling
circle replication of pstbd rna
in the upper left you'll see a circular
plus strand representation of the genome
okay this is by far the most abundant
rna in infected cells it's the
infectious form of the viroid
this is transcribed in the nucleus by
paul ii
and in a rolling circle mechanism which
produces genome concatemers
up to at least seven of these minus
strand concatomers are generated in the
nucleus
and
the minus strands can catamars
subsequently serve as template for plus
strand can catamers in a second pull two
transcription event
now
these uh plus strand concatemers are
then processed to monomers
by a host ribonuclease
and
circularized by host dna ligase
so
the goal of this study
was to assess
paul ii error rate when transcribing
pstvd rna which of course is a
non-native template
and we wanted to do this in the absence
of selection
and we reasoned that the transcription
errors that might be produced
during production of minus strand
concatomers
are not subject
to selection therefore this might be a
way to get at our uh to accomplish our
goal
okay so why why care about viroid and
virus mutation rates well we all heard a
lot about coronavirus mutation lately so
it shouldn't be a surprise
accurate calculation of mutation rates
is critical for evolutionary studies of
course but even more importantly
to evaluate adaptation potential and
we're all very concerned with that
so
estimation of in vivo mutation rates is
a tricky business and it's complicated
by selection
which of course favors some mutations
and eliminates others
now one way investigators have got
around this
is by examining lethal mutations
because these are like unlikely to be
propagated so their frequency should
equal the mutation rate
this
lethal mutation method has several
limitations
probably most obvious being its
inability to survey the entire genome
and we we we wish to do that so we
developed a simple method uh to estimate
pst mutation rate
based on the paul ii error rate
across the entire genome and again in
the absence of selection
now polymerase errors are the major
source of mutation in virus and thyroid
genomes
and so they are key determinants of
adaptation potential
so dna viruses
have
high mutation rates but relatively
uh
well considerably lower than cellular
mutation rates and these range between
10 to the minus 6 to 10 to the minus 8
substitutions per nucleotide per cell
infection this is one way to describe a
mutation rate
rna viruses typically have higher
mutation rates between 10 to the minus 4
to 10 to the minus 6
due to the error-prone nature of viral
rna polymerases which do not proofread
as dna polymerases can coronaviruses by
the way are an exception they do
proofread because they have very big
genomes and the mutation rate would be
too high without a proof reading
function
but
still mutation rate is still high
now using the lethal mutation
method there have been several estimates
made for viroid mutation rates
uh chrysanthemum chlorotic model thyroid
and eggplant latent thyroid for example
have been assessed using the lethal
mutation method and reports have shown
anywhere from one in four
mutation rates ranging from one in four
hundred to one in a thousand nucleotides
these viroids are uh of the absence
absent viridae and they replicate in the
chloroplast using chloroplast rna
polymerases
previous estimates for pstbd
uh have ranged from one in
eight hundred to one in seven thousand
nucleotides in other words
around ten to the minus four one one
mistake and ten to the minus four
nucleotides suggesting that paul two
transcribes thyroid rna more accurately
than the chloroplast enzyme does
um but again these estimates were made
using the lethal mutation method and we
wish to uh we wish to assess
the pul2 error rate
and the psdvd mutation rate across the
entire genome in the absence of
selection
so this is our simple strategy for doing
that
in panel a you'll see a circular plus
strand genome with a red dot that read
that indicates a mutation so this is a
pre-existing mutation in a viroid genome
it's presumably a variant
and it's transcribed by paul ii in the
first in the first
uh
in the first instance to produce a minus
strand dimer
so that mutation should be present in
each of the monomers in other words it
should be shared by each of the monomers
again indicated by the red dots
however a mutation generated during that
transcription process
will not be shared by other monomers
that's the yellow dot
and we refer to those as unshared de
novo mutations those are generated by
paul ii during that transcription event
and so our strategy was to sequence
minus strand dimers and look for
unshared mutations
and the protocol is pretty
straightforward
extracts from the cochianabentamiana
plants this is a model tobacco that we
used as a host
we're infected with pstvd
cdna was prepared from the minus strand
concatemers using a reverse
transcriptase with a low error rate
and dimers were amplified from that cdna
by pcr using a very low error rate
polymerase for that purpose
and
we excise the dimers from the gel which
is shown in the middle
and subjected them to sanger sequencing
to avoid mutations generated during deep
sequencing
we did this in three independent
replicates indicated r a r b r c now
this is a lot of numbers on this table
but i'll talk you through it sort of
summarize things
each of these replicates had similar
numbers of dimers sequenced
including a control on the right
with the red asterisk
so in total
in the red boxes
we sequenced the total of 261 dimers
which is more than 500 genome
equivalents
and more than 187 000 total nucleotides
and in those 187 000 nucleotides we
found 102 unshared de novo mutations
so from that we could calculate an error
rate
of 1 in
1837
nucleotides
by contrast we found only one shared
mutation in all of these experiments
and the control
which we created
starting with a
cloned pstbd dimer we transcribed in
vitro with t3 rna polymerase we found
only one mutation so the background
mutation rate was negligible
now i'm going to go in a little more
detail into the paul 2 error rate and
mutation rate in the next slide
so again
we saw an apparent paul to error rate an
observed error rate if you will of 1 in
1837 nucleotides per transcription cycle
or
to put it another way an error rate of
5.4 times 10 to the minus 4.
from this we extrapolated a mutation
rate because we couldn't look at it
directly we extrapolate it
based on two transcription cycles and
assuming the same error rate for each
again assumptions but the best we could
do
to put it another way
twice the mutations in the same number
of nucleotide sequence
and we came up with an estimated
extrapolated mutation rate of about 1
and 10 to the minus 3 which turns out to
be very similar to the chloroplast
replicating thyroids
now
to think about the paul 2 error rate
again our initial question we're using a
non-native template here what's the paul
2 error rate for mrna transcription and
the best estimates if i could find
were from yeast and c elegans where they
agreed and both were about four times
ten to the minus six per base pair
so comparing the paul to error rate and
assuming similar transcription machinery
in the cochianabentamiana
we can say that paul 2 transcribes pstbd
rna with much lower fidelity than dna
templates about a hundred fold lower
fidelity
nevertheless oh these are some of the
unshared denoble mutations i got ahead
of myself there um that we found and
you'll see
they're listed for all three
replicates and again too many numbers to
look at but
about 30 percent of the dimers sequenced
actually contained an unshared mutation
most of them had only one
some had two or three
and all but one
involved a single base substitution
now some mutations appeared in multiple
genomes it turns out only 64 of those
102 mutations were actually unique
uh
some appeared in multiple genomes and in
many replicates and more than more than
one replicate and mutations observed in
more than one replicate are shown in red
okay
and some of them were found in all three
replicates
despite the low the the vast difference
in fidelity on different kinds of
templates the pul2 mutation spectrum on
dna and pstbdr in it
rna templates was actually quite similar
on the left you'll see transitions were
much much more likely compared to
transversions in it by way of base
substitutions base substitutions were
the most common type of mutation they
accounted for about half of them
single base insertions and single based
deletions each accounted for about a
quarter of the mutations
and the majority of them occurred at
homonucleotide tracts
as
illustrated by the examples here of a
uh 123a 124 which is an insertion after
oh sorry between 123 and 124
and delta 180 u which occurs in a run of
u residues uh around position 180.
so on dna and rna templates paul 2 is
more likely to commit transition errors
versus transversion errors and
preferentially commits indel errors at
homonucleotide tracts
um i think i'm going to skip this slide
here
for the interest of time
um
what you're looking at
is a diagram of the genome again
indicating
the mutations that we found
now to the outside of the genome
uh are our mutations
are the de novo mutations
and
inside our mutations found in progeny
populations i'll talk about that in a
minute
for the moment let's just talk about the
ones on the outside of the genome
sequence
so the the blue arrows are base
substitutions the red arrows indicate
insertion events and the brown triangles
indicate
the lesions
now the arrows indicate the most common
denoble mutations we found
a123 124 we actually found 19 times and
delta delta 180 u we actually found six
times
so
what you'll notice is that the mutations
appear to be clustered in certain
regions of the genome but what really
jumped out at us was that mutations were
mostly absent from the central conserved
region and the terminal conserved region
in fact
if we separately calculate the mutation
rate for those regions compared to the
remainder of the genome we find that
those
two conserved regions are transcribed
with an error rate about four-fold lower
than the remainder of the genome
so
the central conserved region and tc and
and the terminal conserve region
sequence conservation is the consequence
of both function based selection
and selection for greater paul ii
fidelity
now in a previous study
we deep sequenced progeny from pstvd
infected nicotiana benthamiana plants
and i won't go through this in great
detail but we looked for mutation hot
spots that were found in those variants
above a background threshold of 30
million uh
30 reads per million
and we identified
hot spots that were present in 10 unique
sequences per million reads above that
threshold
and when we compared those and those are
shown on the inside of the genome
and when we compared those with the de
novo mutations it was clear that most of
the most of the de novo mutations were
lost
through selection
not surprisingly
this table just lists the 24 mutation
hot spots we identified and the ones in
red were the ones that were also found
uh in our dna in our dimer sequencing
that is de novo mutation so most of them
uh most of the de novo mutations
are not are either eliminated or or
negligibly negligibly present in
in
in the progeny populations
so
to summarize
the pull to error rate
we found uh
transcribing pstvd rna is about a
hundred fold greater than error
frequencies observed in mrna populations
nevertheless paul 2 eric's error
spectrum is similar
on dna and rna templates
the pstvd mutation rate that we
calculated or extrapolated i should say
is very high about one in a thousand
nucleotides which is
approaching one mutation per three
genomes generated which is similar to
the chloroplast replicating virus
and compared
with
progeny population that we studied by
deep sequencing most of those de novo
mutations are eliminated or minimized by
selection
surprisingly and remarkably i think
depaul 2 error rate in replication
critical regions
is four times less four-fold less than
the remainder of the genome
suggesting those regions are selected
both for function and enhanced
transcription fidelity
and this bias paul ii fidelity suggests
a novel strategy to promote replication
while allowing abundant sampling of
sequence space in the remainder of the
genome
and frankly i i would expect that
perhaps other virus viruses in addition
to the virus
have developed such strategies as well
so
that concludes the talk and i just want
to acknowledge
uh once again uh john woo in red there
for
essentially doing all the work that i
talked to you about today
and
thank you for listening and thank you
for your time
thanks very much